hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play condemned criminal origins
okay the suspect has my gun I'm all
alone here's some medical stuff thank
you
gimme no I'm perfectly healthy okay this
is the other side of that wall where I
was blocked off from before so hey I see
you hey hey give me back my gun
Ernest I'm over here I probably couldn't
have followed him anyway I'm old whoa
hello hey hey ha oh you wanna mess with
me oh wow don't even try it
Oh funk oh where you come from
oh no oh no oh no kick yeah wow that
hurt I'm gonna go back and get the UH
the med kit stuff cuz apparently these
guys hurt when I don't have a gun oh I
can't sprint for crap I really am a fat
old police officer or FBI agent Stewart
okay I'm good oh is it why can't I carry
those with me I don't know but now my
weapon is covered in blood that's always
nice so it's a good day on the force
when you to kill as many people as you
possibly want or can
actually that sounds terrible as a bad
day alright so I'm gonna try this one
cuz it's got nails in it I think it
might be better wait what
block what I can block oh I can block oh
wow alright then uh eyes huh ha ha ha ha
nothing
ain't nothing nothing nothing
ah block I got ya I got ya
oops don't you Reno you're nothing
get outta here Oh investigate is that is
that is that what time it is for and
found it what ha ha ha ha
I picked up a dead bird this guy's got
issues this guy's got some serious
issues
funk alright so that was um that I've
got a nice plump dead bird now listen
you want me to kill those rats and get
them he'll be nice good oh I don't need
that I'm perfectly healthy anybody out
here am I just going in a circle
oh here we go it's hard to tell under
the stairs nothing that some homeless
guys sleeping please I said alright
there we go
up the stairs join crazies crazies I
know they're gonna be crazies Thomas
Thomas answer me what happened we heard
an explosion
oh yeah Lowen it's just a fuse box
shorted I seem to be trapped over here
and I believe the suspect has my gun
uh-huh well the hell did that happen
here take this fire axe and chop your
way out okie dokie crap Wow right
through the window they're tools you
didn't tell me to move around berries
even use things like an axe or in a
sledgehammer as a weapon they do a great
deal of damage but they're slow let pipe
busts heads faster if that's what you
prefer back riah you need the tips
Becker and I'll go around the other way
try and stay in one piece oh and one
more thing if you find yourself in a
sticky situation
use your taser to temporarily stun your
target if you're close enough you'll
find it a great way to disarm the slug
of his weapon okay how do I uh ha ha ha
how do i oh ok
fire mouse button - AHA Nagy's I just
wasted that oh it recharges yay
unlimited taser ha ha ha ha ok and I got
an ice axe - I love ya grip yeah here's
Johnny I bet no one's ever made that
joke ever
hey hey hey hey stop throwing your
temper tantrum take that somewhere else
what you got we got buddy we got oh yeah
whap oh my gonna be head these guys I'm
down but the other one go
mr. crazy I got a Taser for you
anybody in here no yes no yes No
No ah ha there you are I see you now
what no not a pipe got here I got a
freaking axe why would I need a pipe
wonder when they're gonna give me back a
gun
hi I'll see you I'll see you this is the
same guy that was running away from you
before now I kind of seem like the crazy
murderer carrying an axe stalking a guy
through a hallway ah here he comes
nope didn't think so Oh what the heck no
no you did yeah and now you don't it
sorry about that oh no I'm not haha
can't you can't sneak up whoa oh I
thought I'd be headed in places a big
cloud of blood ha ha ha I'm a crazy axe
murderer nothing can stand in my way I
don't know why this guy's having such
trouble swinging his axe I mean back in
nightmare house - the guy was able to
swing a full-sized axis like that we're
pretty impressive actually
ok so large pipe if you know what I mean
all right sir
let's see hmm
getting dark you are not getting dark
and it's getting quiet ah okay
hey hider oh hello
coming to the scenic gonna see me coming
to savor Oh
one shop lack of bow oh damn it
surprised me didn't scare me you
surprised me wonder all right
yeah I got I gotta do some real quick
cuz I I brought these sounds down but I
remember right I can change the sounds
in post now so I just wanna make sure
you guys feel the environment too oh
it's still Sun outside you're kidding me
this is not it's way too dark in here to
be sunny outside
alright whatever
I guess they don't ah hey stop being a
douche how does it feel to be on this
end of the gum uh not so bad but listen
you bastard don't mess this up for us uh
I'm try not hold on the scene of
righteousness by letting me with that
end up pretty good and the path takes
strong stories please drop the weapon
now
what uh what be ready for death agent
Thomas it shall come visit him again
other person what oh oh how did he how
did he drop the both of them like right
one after another
ah really ah no way I found one of six
birds oh man
zero of three metal pieces oh man I did
poorly but I'm not in this to for
completion okay report to 3-0 strange
bird deaths throughout the city bodies
of dead birds now litter city streets
and public parts hard-hit areas have
little reported literally thousands of
bodies while other areas of city have
seen very few birds at all time your
kicks carefully for just after a melee
swing what the hell
no you there I crashed on a freaking car
what
ah you so ugly yep
still ugly oh I should have expected
something was gonna happen haha I guess
this is where the game starts to get a
little freaky hello Ethan oh hi who are
you what is going on
calm yourself my name is Malcolm Van
Horn
but the stupids a great friend of your
father's I doubt that yes I remember you
know your own time ago but why are you
here now look I know where you are
well I was nearby an unfortunate scene
you did your best but it could not be
helped
the detectives they're dead shot with
your weapon and you will be blamed for
their deaths connections I believe that
ridiculous I'll just tell them what tell
them the truth they have already decided
the truth this is insane I can't just
give up the bureau it's already been
taken from you now join me and help
yourself
damn take your bag and head across to
the metro station I will meet you later
hi hey buddy
oh my Ethan you must trust me I am here
to help
now go I doubt that very much I've
learned in my experience in all of these
types of games never to trust anyone who
says there
hey I'm gonna call it that guy's a
figment of my imagination
same with the convict I'm really the
killer what's your business here
my name is Malcolm Van Horn I'm an old
friend of the family he invited me to
stay here but he must have forgot I was
arriving today hmm
clear we need to search the premises uh
I think they're talking up there okay
now haha when shovel well this seems
wheel uh unwieldy fight whatever his
chef won't yeah that was surprisingly
effective I didn't know that all
electronic locks could be defeated by
such a shovel I like how it's blocking
my right side camera
Oh anything under the stairs yes no yes
no ah yes
maybe dead bird oh come on I'm trying
here I'm trying I'm trying my best coach
I'm a small pipe there we go now you
guys can actually see what's going on
ah alright then Oh
that doesn't seem good wait here we go
lube yeah receiving imagedata you're a
lucky man Thomas I'm still here
ha hi God I thought they would have
suspended my lab access I would have
accelerate it hasn't occurred to me I
didn't kill those guys I know Thomas
well I'm not certain what I do or don't
know but I'm pretty sure I still trust
you
Thank You Laurie understood so what
about the photos
Oh standing on ceremony man uh-huh it's
a picture of you Thomas in your
apartment I remember that he is so far
from last year's Christmas party yeah if
you please the injury from within the
metro station it appears so I'm also
seeing smudges across the face of the
photo okay a good sample and transplant
to me okay a good sample of what liquid
need to find and use my research tool
maybe no uh-huh that's what I yeah
lays or what I want to lays aureate Oh
Harold
no I want to lays or
go away light I'm trying to days or
things Gemma
where is it
it was bright green on the photos I said
you can't say I don't see it you you
can't say I don't see it on the photo
set I don't know I don't know
let's see lookie lookie lookie ah ha ha
ha actually I'm gonna hold off on
investigating that because I am all out
of time so thank you all so much for
watching hope you're enjoying it so far
and as always I will see you in the next
part
bye bye